hi everyone sal khan here welcome to the
homeroom live stream we have a very
exciting guest today we're gonna have
john dickerson who is
works for uh 60 minutes a cbs
contributing analyst uh contributes to
the atlantic and also has written the
hardest job in the world so a lot to
talk about especially with the election
coming up and kind of our government and
the history of the united states if you
have any questions about that feel free
to start putting them in the message
boards wherever you are watching this
then our team members are going to
surface it to myself and john but before
we jump into that very exciting
conversation i'll give my standard
reminders first of all reminder that
khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization
and we can only do what we do
with philanthropic support from folks
like yourself so if you're in a position
to do so please think about going to
khan academy.org
donate and making a donation
i also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations that have
stepped up during covid when they
realized that we were already running a
deficit before covid and that deficit
only grew as we had to have higher
server costs and accelerate a whole
bunch of programs so special thanks to
bank of america google.org att fasting
of artists and the many many other
supporters that have supported khan
academy through the years and especially
all of y'all who have continued to
support us through kovid it's the only
way we can do what we do and the last
announcement
just reminding everyone that you can get
a version of this live stream in podcast
format wherever you get your podcast
homeroom with sal
the podcast
so with that i'm excited to introduce
john dickerson 60 minutes correspondent
cbs contributing analyst you contribute
to the atlantic you do a lot of things i
mean any one of the things i just
mentioned would be
more than a full-time job
but good to see you john
it's great to be with you again sal
so maybe a good place to start i have a
ton of questions but obviously we're
days away from an election you know
every election i think always feels
special and different but this one feels
more different than normal obviously
it's happening in very unusual
circumstances
how are you thinking about it
well i think um you're right there's so
the most the basic reason it feels
different is that we are holding or
trying to hold an election in the in the
time of a pandemic so that every vote
cast and counted is um under different
scrutiny st some states have had to
create entirely new ways of voting um so
that would be just be the basic
big challenge of the moment we're in
we are also in a highly contentious
moment in which the president who is
usually the guardian and steward of that
system which is the bedrock of the
american system which is a form for
voting that allows the peaceful transfer
of power or the peaceful maintenance of
power it's basically the first block in
the building block of american
government the president has been
questioning challenging poking prodding
at that basic brick in the in the
structure of america by questioning
whether the votes will be um will be
honest whether the vote counting and the
way it's being done uh is uh somehow
going to throw the result into question
so you have
the voting pandemic and then you have
the basically the most popular
well-known figure in american politics
calling that into question so those are
just two things and then of course you
have a series of issues that are at the
center of the election which are major
and big and need to be addressed
pandemic is one the economic situation
in america is other is the other and
then the ongoing racial um uh
debate questions protests about equality
in america and whether that is broadly
shared or broadly available to and
particularly to black americans
and how do you think i know predicting
the future is always a hard thing to do
but let's let's try a little bit how do
you think it's going to play out i'm
giving everything you just talked about
you know on election day this isn't
going to be a typical election day where
by midnight or 1 a.m people are going to
say oh it looks like you know
so-and-so's the next president
right
here's what i'm looking for in terms of
the way it plays out the one thing to
watch is right now the the early vote
that's taking place both both in person
and by mail
there are some states like florida and
arizona that start the counting early
and those are states that we should all
kind of look to on election night
i've become particularly interested in
arizona they start counting two weeks
before they've been voting early since
1996 so they're pretty good at doing it
about 90 of the vote will be counted
before uh election day in arizona which
means you're going to have durable
a durable counting process there um and
uh so we're gonna so we have the early
vote going on then we look at the states
that are able to process those votes so
that we'll get an answer on election
night then we've got to look at the
votes that are being cast on election
day and one of the splits people should
look for is that a lot of democrats are
voting early it's likely that the bulk
of the republican vote will be on
election day
so we should all be prepared for some
numbers that come in that show perhaps
joe biden winning because of the early
vote but then maybe change once once
some states start to count their
in-person vote during the day and we
should all be ready and prepared if it's
a close election for the election to be
determined
maybe into the next day after election
day or maybe even some days down beyond
that
on the other hand early in the evening
we'll get results from some east coast
states florida north carolina in
particular georgia that will tell us
something about the way the night is
trending and it could be even though
everybody is prepared for a long
election week it could be that we get a
signal early in the night from some of
those states that it's going to go
one way uh because the turnout is just
you know uh been for one candidate or
another and we could get an early result
so everybody's preparing for a long
counting process but that doesn't mean
that's the only kind of answer we might
get once the votes start being counted
and i just want to make sure i
understand the logistics or or how the
information gets out as we approach
election day so even a place like
arizona where they start the counting
ahead of time do they release that
information as they have it is that
where we see like you know the precincts
reporting and all that how does that get
out there
this is my favorite fact about arizona
at the moment accounting is going on and
it is in a computer somewhere the
tabulation so what they do is they they
open the ballot they check the the
information on the ballot against the
voter file they check the signatures
they make sure it's an uh
an actual valid ballot and then they
tabulate it those tabulations are
sitting in a computer
and will sit in a computer until
election day it's not hooked up to the
internet it is it is a number inside the
computer that nobody knows
then once the polls close in arizona
election day they will release that
tabulation so that's the tabulation of
the early mail and in-person vote and so
you'll get a big kind of gurgle of
results and then
slowly over time they will add in the
votes on election day and so those the
votes by machine on election day but
then also some people will drop off
their ballots on election day which
means
that they've gotten an early ballot and
then it will have to be assessed they'll
compare the signatures they'll compare
it to the voter roll and so that'll take
a little bit of time arizona even though
they have a time tested
well stressed um vote by mail process
they've had some elections recently
where the result on election night has
been different than the results several
days later because of that because of
that counting process now that's just in
arizona every state has a different
process it's why some of the states
people are most fascinated by
pennsylvania michigan and wisconsin
those are three states that donald trump
won in 2016 which was a part of his
surprise upset victory those are i call
them the headache states because
pennsylvania doesn't start processing
ballots until election day
so if they their process is kind of slow
and it may mean that we don't get a
result if those states are close you may
not get a result for a few days and
there will be lots of things to bicker
over in the way that they count their um
their ballots so every state does it
differently some better than others
and a lot of questions are coming in
related to what you just talked about
from youtube mark r thompson says why
can't all states do what arizona is
doing
well
uh we may find that um that they may all
start to try and do that um the
principle has been that um local control
you know in the united states where um
this is best handled by people closest
to the ones doing the actual voting and
the upside also of it is when we think
about hacking and disruption from
foreign adversaries or anybody who would
try to seize power in america from the
local perspective very hard to do when
you have
many many different kinds of voting
systems um and so in a way
the inefficiency of having so many
different systems has a slight benefit
in that it's harder to disrupt because
you'd have to learn how to disrupt each
little play each little county sometimes
and in some states the rules are
different by county um so there's a
there's a way in which the inefficiency
actually protects us a little bit but
and i should just add they we have tried
as a as a country to reform our voting
process
during the ford administration carter
administration obama administration and
their big
binders full of analysis on how to make
voting easier and better and it never
quite happens uh for a variety of
reasons in part because the federal
government can't tell the states what to
do
but maybe after the the
embarrassing
delays and confusion here there might be
maybe there will be a new push to uh to
improve things
i like that point that's the first time
i heard kind of our fragmentation of our
of our voting system as a feature and
not a bug uh but it does make sense it
does make it harder to game because you
have to literally game it at a at least
at a state level probably at a local
level and that goes into another
question you know you you you alluded to
the fact that donald trump has
said a few times that he's skeptical of
some of the mail-in early voting that
maybe their you know the election might
be called into question from youtube mr
specter is asking will it be a fair
election how will they make sure the
votes are fair and nothing is
well each of the individual states and
the secretaries of states in the states
will uh has a process for doing that um
part one thing people should really keep
in mind is that a lot of these states
and particularly ones that have had
close elections
have a time tested and honored
way of figuring out whether there's any
fraud the reason there is so little
fraud
is it's really hard to do
and when they have found fraud on
election day or through voting it's been
found out
so um
it might take a little while um in some
states because they have a kind of
multi-level process to make sure that
the voting that's taking place
is honorable and true but the length of
time that it's taking means that they
are
doing their their work they are checking
their um you know they're doing their
math again they're not rushing through
the process and so delay and um it might
be a little irritating in this in this
world where we would all like everything
instantaneously but it is the sign of of
diligent work going forward that is
actually going to protect the durability
of the vote
so what we can rely on is the systems
within the states
um and the fact that everybody's been
worried about what voting in a pandemic
is going to be like and so there are a
lot of people who are watching um and
and while some states have had rigorous
debates over the number of polling
places and the number of drop-offs spots
for early ballots there are a lot of
people paying attention um and so it's a
little bit harder to do a sleight of
hand or some kind of fraud with so many
eyes on what's taking place
and you know one thing you you brought
up and that you know you're talking
about that gives
me confidence um in in what is happening
but even in your kind of it sounds like
almost not worst case but
not great scenarios you have it maybe a
few days past election day you know i
was hearing these scenarios i haven't
heard them as much recently where people
think it might take weeks and it might
be disputed and it might go
you know depending on on how it's
disputed if some states don't want to
you know say that they've have a final
tally that it could go to the state
legislatures i've been hearing all of
these other kind of byzantine worst case
scenarios do you think any of those are
happening or that just kind of
scare-mongering of like an absolute
disaster scenario
well it's a it's a good question i could
cook up some truly awful scenarios um
i mean basically the closer it is
the more
um
tricky it might get
because a if it's close it means that um
every tiny little
vote really could matter remember what
happened in 2000 in florida you had a
committee of people obsessing about the
tiny pieces of paper that hung from the
punch ballots the chads as you'll
remember
which really showed how you can funnel
the entire intensity of the american
political system and the power that is
exchanged in elections down to a tiny
piece of paper that is basically barely
bigger than the head of a pencil
so it can get really weird really fast
and um if it's not close however then
then there might be some sloppiness
there always is in an election it's a
massive undertaking we might have you
know between 150 160 million people in
america it is not something that ever
goes off with 100
purity um just because of human activity
at that scale has
bumps and messiness and and and an
occasional untucked shirt tale
but if it's so but if it's not close a
little messiness can be accommodated by
the overwhelming result for one of the
two candidates um and i think that
so basically i've tried not to sketch
the
total disaster scenarios because while
people are prepared for them and
everybody should be emotionally prepared
for complexity
um i also think that if we get too
uh up on tiptoe and get to um talk too
much about how awful it all could be
it sets the stage for mischief makers
who some of whom are domestic some of
whom are are from our adversaries who um
in a highly heightened atmosphere can
throw in just a little disinformation
and if everybody's already so keyed up
that little bit of information will
cause people to go pinballing all over
the place
and so
one of our jobs in the press is to
try to keep the eye on the ball what's
the most important thing um and not go
through a kind of doom scrolling of all
the possible awful things that might
happen um
and and in fact
teach people or remind people that you
know this is going to be a developing
story on election night and and to to
ignore rumors
and to practice some restraint in
handling the incoming information um
because you know it might take a
slightly winding path and don't mistake
the natural wideness of the ocean county
process for anything having gone wrong
um if they do that there will be less
chaos on election day
and you're touching on actually the next
question that's come through on this
notion of foreign influence mischief
makers polarization from facebook john
lavelle asks the foreign influence that
has taken place in our country has
fueled the division that threatens the
union and has been very successful the
two tribes are in each other's throat
the question is who has helped widen the
gap and i'll expand that a little bit i
i do sometimes wonder how successful
have the foreign influence actually been
it seems like there's evidence that it's
been going on but how successful has it
been or has it been more of our own
making
through
polarization through social media or
even the media itself changing and kind
of polarizing
well the answer to that question is yes
which is to say
certainly we had foreign adversaries who
were trying through a variety of
different methods um facebook groups
phony ads um
attempted voter suppression to tinker
with american politics but i think one
of the most potentially
powerful things they did was
in a nation uh where political combat is
so corrosive among the highly online and
the highly engaged which is not the
majority of our country and it's not
even the majority of voters but
nevertheless it does represent a lot of
people on social media who who can
affect news coverage who can affect the
the culture in which voting takes place
that's where when you throw
disinformation into the middle of that
kind of swarm
where we're already bickering and
short-tempered and questioning motives
in our political debate
it it it has a it has an explosive
effect so it's not in some cases it's
not even um
misinformation it's just um
the coarsest possible information which
then causes a reaction and a counter
reaction from each side
so um
the the the partisanship in america
among political obsessives has gotten
much much worse um both in the way they
think about the parties and the way in
which they think about the opposite
members of the parties you know about
the polling
that long ago people who were political
obsessives would be okay with one of
their offspring marrying somebody of the
other party
now that number is down it might be in
the teens of political obsessives who
would be all right with one of their
offspring marrying a member of the other
party those are the political obsessives
there's also a lot of work that's done
on on voters that finds that basically
about 80 of the voters are not obsessed
and thinking the absolute worst of the
other party now they can get there
pretty fast
if you
if you get into a conversation with them
and you misbehave and you um and you
treat them as um you know sub-human
because of the party they belong to but
mostly the people who spend a lot of
time on social media and the people who
are who represent the worst in our
political dialogue are actually a
relatively small percentage of the
elector the electorate and an even
smaller percentage of the american
people
and
you know we this polarization where you
think it's going to lead to do you think
it depends on the outcome of the
election do you think we have some just
you know structural trends because of
social media and it's not like the
russians and the iranians and the
chinese are going to disappear overnight
i mean is there some way that we
converge back to um and is there any
lessons from history that tell us that
okay we can clearly i mean obviously
we've had a civil war so things have
gotten bad in the past
how do we heal what's it gonna look like
in 20 years
yeah well the civil war the civil war
example is the most dangerous one of
course which is that we only heal after
we tear ourselves apart
um and so you'd hate to
you hate you'd hate to have to see
reform come out of that kind of hot
stove moment um because of the carnage
that would be required to create that
kind of wake-up call for the whole
country
there are um
i mean i think the best case for
getting out of our current fix
is probably a combination of two things
one would be a considerable political
defeat
of one of the two parties which would
change the political incentives for the
individual members in the party
to not listen to the base of their party
but listen to the larger country the
problem is and i'm gonna be
general here although um you know at the
moment because donald trump is the
president the power he holds over
republicans in his party
um is is tremendous and and you know as
jared kushner says this is donald
trump's republican party and so if
you're a republican member of the house
or senate you are judged by your
president and also the partisans in your
party uh by whether or not you're um you
support donald trump
well that's um
not really the way the founders intended
it to operate they wanted a system in
which lawmakers used their reason to
evaluate the questions of the day and
political affiliation and maintaining
political power was what they feared
but the system is where it is
so what you need is this is something to
happen that breaks the link between
individual members of a party and the
group interest of that party that
basically says to people
gee
just supporting my team has caused this
enormous electoral loss
i should probably go back to
what the people want me to care about
which is whatever it happens to be
um and so you sever the extreme
adhesion between individual candidates
and their parties
one of the ways you do that is
and that has to probably happen through
an event in other words a massive
electoral loss
it would then potentially open the door
to some reforms and what the reforms
would do is they would break down the
structural impediments to bipartisanship
which i won't go into but which i go to
into in some length in my book but which
um the death of split ticket voting the
fact that we all live near each other
and therefore
if you're a republican you tend to live
on a block full of republicans now in a
way that you didn't in the 70s um
gerrymandering all kinds of other
structural um
parts of the system that that accentuate
partisanship um you would need something
to basically have some reforms that
would break apart those structural uh
sorting techniques that have created or
i shouldn't say they've both created and
locked in the partisanship we have now
yeah no i mean it's it's a fascinating
thing of how it could evolve but that
makes a ton of sense you know going to
your your book the hardest job in the
world when you're referring to the
presidency i can think of other hard
jobs too but that one does seem hard um
from youtube nish786 says you make the
case in the hardest job in the world
that the demands of the american
presidency have grown impossible for any
one person to fulfill
what problems does that pose and i'll
add to nish's question what
how do you fix that i mean it sounds
like a pretty hard thing to fix
well and thank you for the question and
thanks for reading the book um
so we were talking about just some of
the problems with the modern presidency
which is partisanship
which has locked up congress which means
that the president no longer has a
willing partner uh or no longer has the
willing partner of a kind that the
founders wanted in congress um something
that uh that operates
independently to
address the big challenges of the day in
a way that accommodates the diversity of
the country
what we have now is as congress is
less able to do its job effectively a
lot of the decision making gets thrown
over onto the president's plate and then
the president has to use the weak tools
of the office which are not universally
applicable to all the problems of the
day
to through executive orders and other
ways to try to address some of the
issues that americans care about well
executive orders and executive action
and work through the administrative
agencies is a weak way to do it
basically it doesn't it doesn't get the
job done
and when presidents act in ways that are
seen as unilateral by the opposite
political party it encourages the
opposite political party to be very
angry if you if you can work things
through congress the opposite political
party at least has a voice and a
structure now some people would argue
about that with respect to the recent
supreme court um fights that have gone
on but nevertheless when congress is
working as it's intended it's a it's
basically a structure for having
arguments and for seeing who wins that
argument and then at least making the
losers feel like the system was fair
enough so that they'll they can live to
fight another day what you don't want in
any system is where people feel like
they were basically
maneuvered by the structure of the
system to a bad result and they really
couldn't change anything
so some of the structural changes in
congress we've been talking about we
need to change the president you know
has accumulated power ever since
basically the you can put finger down
anywhere in the timeline but let's say
basically the new deal and the second
world war so
that's hard power to give back and they
don't want to do that but as americans
we can stop looking to the president
every time we want a political solution
and we can stop um rewarding presidents
who promise that they alone can do it as
donald trump promised you need to you
need to
elevate presidents who operate in the
american system as it should work not as
an american system in which they are the
lone superpower sorry the lone superhero
who can through force of their will and
skill solve all of america's problems
it's not the way the government is
supposed to work and we should stop
thinking that's the way it's supposed to
work because it just leads to
frustration
yeah although i wonder about that i mean
even in corporate america we tend to
have you know the the ceo we you know
elon musk is sending rockets to
to space well no it's elon musk plus a
lot of other people are doing it you
know and stuff like that right steve
jobs credit well steve jobs and a lot of
other people
well and but in the corporate world at
least that's there's the chance that
that's more likely to happen because the
ceo can have you know absolute power if
they've designed the organization that
way even if a president wanted absolute
power they don't have it um and they've
got and then so it's it's it's sort of
the worst of both worlds because if we
think of them as an all-powerful ceo but
then don't give them the tools to do the
job then they both
make claims like they're going to be the
elon musk of the government but then
don't have the ability to actually do it
um and you know there's there's not
really a feedback mechanism that there
is in the corporate world
basically with the presidency there's
one feedback mechanism reelection
and
most of them take intermediate feedback
mechanisms if they lose a midterm or if
their polls go down
but if a president has a strong enough
pain threshold or a high enough pain
threshold i should say then they can
they can you know power through and and
face no real feedback other than um
other than the election after four years
because congress is no longer a feedback
mechanism because everything is so
connected now if you're a senator
basically as a republican senator if
you're running your voters want to know
are you for the president or against him
the rest is secondary and that's i say
that having interviewed a lot of
republican senators running
this if i could talk to you for hours
especially given
the world that we're in right now but
just in the last question you know as a
member of the media uh and you know the
type of journalism i've followed you
many years even before we first met and
and we've had many conversations like
this even when we're on camera so deep
respect you know you're kind of like the
journalists that i always imagined are
like the people there trying to be the
truth seekers and they're reading the
history books and they're writing the
history books
what do you what advice would you have
for kids out there who might be watching
or people of any age or it's like well
you know
we're not we're past walter cronkite
somehow and the fourth estate of
journalism and social media has somehow
ruined everything and you know there
isn't you know there's everyone's
version of the truth now so what advice
would you have to someone who wants to
become a journalist and why should they
be excited about that
well i think that my advice would be um
and it goes back to khan academy what
you know what is one of the great things
about what you've created is
it is to allow people who are curious
to to learn and to follow that curiosity
and to in the process of following that
curiosity develop the school the skills
for understanding their world so
critical thinking um
and and curiosity and critical thinking
are necessary to live a meaningful life
i think
it turns out also that they're what
should fuel you as a journalist um and
so one of the one of the things i think
whether you're interested in journalism
or not um seeking out your own answers
following your own curiosity not just
what happened but why it happened
um for yourself not because you're
skeptical and you think everybody's
trying to lie to you but because you
know that when you investigate the why
of things when you go look it up on your
own when you follow your own path of
your curiosity it's rewarding and you
gain in a democratic system you gain
control over the world around you by
understanding what's happening events
don't come plopping on you
you understand what's happening and so
you feel some control in a frantic world
where where things can seem
out of control
and so
what i would say is anybody who is
curious and a critical thinker
can then go get a job where you have a
license to be curious and hopefully use
those critical thinking skills
to um to follow your curiosity
the final thing i would say is for
anybody once become a journalist or
anyone who wants to engage in journalism
just like if they're if they're learning
through khan academy or any other
learning process
experimentation and understanding is not
a straight line there are things that we
once believed about the movement of the
planets in the heavens that we've now
changed our thinking about einstein was
a genius who saw a head of entire
generations of thinkers but he also got
a lot wrong
and he when he found out he had gotten
something wrong he didn't feel glum
about it he was delighted because it
meant that he now knew the right answer
he now could pursue a whole new set of
curiosities
and i think as consumers of journalism
and of any information is to understand
that being wrong
is not always the product of somebody
who has ill intent or somebody who is
acting in bad faith
there are plenty of those people to be
sure
but if we understand that the pursuit of
knowledge is sometimes a crooked path
then we won't get all
undone every time we learned something
that we thought might not be true the
day before when we accumulation of
knowledge is a kind of crooked path and
we need to know that and we need to know
that about our journalism in its best
form it's self-correcting the more you
learn the more you learn and the better
informed you are but we should make sure
we think of it in that way and don't
always think oh well
you know they said it was going to be
this way and it turned out to be that
way and therefore everything they always
say is without merit that's not true in
life and we shouldn't think about it
when we it's not true in the way we
receive our information a little more um
understanding of the way we receive our
information will help us to be better
informed
no i love that and that seems applicable
to journalism the media and life to just
be constantly truth-seeking and not
tying your identity or ego to a certain
set current fact base and always be open
to new ideas john thank you so much this
was a real treat especially given the
timing hopefully we can debrief and see
uh how how correct your prognostications
were in a couple weeks or months
well i will i would love to do it and
it's always a pleasure to be with you so
um thanks for giving me the opportunity
thank you john
see you soon so thanks everyone for for
for joining uh always a fun conversation
you know john really is one of those
journalists you know i've had the
pleasure of getting to have kind of just
random conversations with them that go a
lot like the conversation we just had
but he definitely gives you a spark of
curiosity around you know the the the
messiness but also the beauty of what
makes a society a society what makes a
government a government um and and i
really do think he's he's you know that
that form of journalism that we need a
lot more of
more more than ever uh but just as a
reminder for tomorrow another really
great guest we're going to have vivek
murthy former surgeon general and
we're going to talk about you imagine a
lot of things healthcare
what's going on with kovid um and you
know probably a little bit of you know
what the surgeon general does and the
role of government and all of this as
well so i look forward to having that
conversation so please join us tomorrow
with uh on the homeroom same time talk
to y'all later
you